étrangère
[Musique]
cette communauté a un désert alimentaire il y a
comme une épicerie dans un certain
kilométrage et sinon il y a des
dépanneurs qui généralement
[Musique]
étrangère [
Musique]
vous savez, les noirs, nous souffrons le plus d'
hypertension artérielle, de diabète, de
maladie cardiaque et c'est  tout cela est lié à ce que
nous mettons dans notre corps,
merci
[Musique]
donc sortir ici et avoir accès à des
fruits et légumes frais, cela peut
vraiment vous aider à atténuer beaucoup de
ces problèmes, il est donc très important
que tout le monde ait accès à des fruits et légumes frais.
fruits et légumes
[Musique]
mais je pense que les déserts alimentaires sont très faciles
à éliminer mais nous avons dû investir nos
ressources pour les éliminer en
investissant notre argent nos subventions nos
efforts bénévoles nous devons élire
des personnes qui mettent leur énergie
à résoudre ces problèmes parce que
ils sont résolubles ils sont résolubles
ils sont juste sous-financés
merci